close game good work blood
sweat for that keep it going
[Music]
all right boys me versus charlie if you
don't know we have played
12 games in the past the record is six
to nine 15 games that's bad math
i am up but the tale doesn't end there
because he beat me in the last paul
champs in the finals of the consolation
bracket
which was the most viewed chess match of
all time on a streaming service
at that point all right well here we are
we have the first game with
ludwig as black and moist as white we
started off with e4 alright let's see if
ludwig has
anything prepared oh maybe i just got
lucky ludwig's afk
he overdosed come on
wait if he doesn't move it give me that
game aborted
all
[Music]
all right well uh children plug your
ears
yeah but yeah it is that bad standard oh
and he pushes h3 which is what you were
just saying
would be an issue because now um not
only is he not defending the knight on
f3 a second time or trying to put his
king to safety but he's baiting ludwig
into making the correct move but ludwig
decides to recreate instead into playing
the right move
is the funniest line i have seen maybe i
go on the offensive
oh there it is double attack this piece
oh and this piece
poggers
because i'm defended i didn't realize
that maybe the move
now is here god ludwig's stonks going up
you guys queen f1 would i just bring
this over
and the crazy thing is if he takes on f3
and
moist decides to take his knight he has
checkmate in two
um so i think we should take a listen in
on charlie here
and see if he notices this checkmate
because it is really crucial he might
not be talking with one minute but
um you guys can
can't imagine what's going on in his
head yes exactly behind that that
totally relates
control over this but i can't really
capitalize on it now
okay so he needs to see that good he
took back so that is
the move that he had to see in order to
survive and if queen takes the bishop
then he can recapture the knight and at
least he has a chance there even though
his king is very naked
there's a lot of chances for both sides
to make mistakes especially as we are
going to see a time scramble remember
there's only five seconds of increment
barely enough time to prevent yourself
from flagging these both of these
players still have to find
very very good moves and i think he has
to play knight f3 here to fork the two
rooks
otherwise rook h5 is gonna come and he's
gonna end up
losing his knight on g5 so he has to be
willing to go for the trade
or he could play rook no not even rook
g7 works no rookie
yeah richard seven there's actually d5
taking away the square from the knight
making sure the knight can't go to e6
and protect that
f3's they only move oh no time ten
seconds ten seconds oh no
okay nice collapse for ludwig in the
chat that was a good move to see with so
little time
bringing the king in nice job oh
this simplification wow
wow that that deserves
a clap honestly like it's going to be a
coupon
game moist is up two pawns
he is going to be pushing the spawn um
even there's no still mate here right
after king of a king of six there is no
still mate because
ludwig still has pawns to move um now
it's just a matter of
finding the win and one of the easier
ways i think moyes has spotted it is to
actually just bring his king over to
capture all of ludwig's pawns uh yeah he
could have taken and brought his king
but honestly with the time pressure
he just needs to see at some point you
can either push the pawn or take
whatever he wants to go for he's trying
to go for that promotion
and he has mates in a few moves here
yeah i mean ludwig's position looked so
promising when he played knight takes g4
but once again you have to remember if
you don't if you're sacrificing and you
don't play the most forcing moves or try
to check your opponent within the next
couple of moves
this is what might happen uh you might
end up in
one of these worst end games since you
are down material
and that was part of the risk with the
sake you know you still get style points
for going for it and it could have
worked out
that's the cool thing with these
opposite side castles
close game good work blood
i hate looking at analysis because they
make me feel like pure
man i was playing perfect too in that
stretch up until here
all right well we got another game all
right and we have a sicilian
by moist critical and uh ludwig is
playing the anti-sicilian line with c3
which i think is a great line for
beginners because it helps you get both
your pawns into the center
and whoa he is pushing all the way
because
moist misplayed a little bit with g6
maybe he hurried a little bit
um i mean so technically
this is playable for black obviously
ludwig's position
is already looking very good on move
five you know he's
he's got the center pawns he's got d5
and e4 push
meanwhile moist has to retreat his
knight to b8
as i was saying that he played knight to
e5 and now he's going to get him
or his knight he was less prepared for
the sicilian than he was for the
scandinavian
i feel like he played the scandinavian
really well
that is quite an acute observation
ludwig
okay great trade by ludwig
oh and he's just trading everything but
oh he blundered he could also take me
actually
oh my god okay so bishop takes c3
is a check or he might castle okay no
yeah he reserves the right to castle
moyes played that too fast
yeah i didn't think that through
actually but i do like that i got the
queen off the board
oh my god moist could have come back
it's it is still a move that charlie has
to find
absolutely um so rook d7 charlie has to
play it
but isn't there still rook c1 and rook
c7 i mean you can't really get away from
that plan
this is true this is very true uh okay
rick takes e4 we do see
d7 um charlie has to start bringing his
king
okay well this move is a bit unfortunate
because you're actually
helping okay oh my god he just goes
straight for it i like i like this i
like this
nice that was epic oh my god
i love this technique here
check queen maybe
[Music]
he's so calm cool calmly collected okay
and i like that moist critical is
bringing his
king into the action the thing that he
has going for him is that at least he
has these two past pawns
and look i'm not gonna say his chances
are high but he has a chance to try to
do something if ludwig somehow decides
to move his night out of the way
for for content or something for content
quick critical should offer him 100 subs
if he moves his knight all the way to
the other side of the board that seems
to motivate ludwig
unfortunately even the knight was all
the way on the other side of the board
you still can't push e2 because rook
takes e2
is there okay well
oh that's true critical let's listen in
on him
it sucks because he basically lost the
game in the first six moves or got a
losing position
and he fought so hard but there just
wasn't enough
firepower in his position
i know you guys it's it's tough but um
everybody has those days
sorry go ahead go ahead i was going to
say on the bright side
a tie break from them which is going to
be super fun
actually that's this is the wrong way
for a drone this is true and that tie
breaker
is going to be very exciting as a
reminder the tiebreaker is in
armageddon and if you have never heard
of that word before
it is simply white has five minutes
black has four minutes
but black can either win or draw
the game in order to get the win
yeah and uh those are always very fun
because it's going to have a decisive
result regardless
i feel like you're setting me up to say
something i just didn't say anything
i i was actually just trying not to cut
off charlie
um but the way we're gonna decide who
gets white and who gets black
is whoever has the highest accuracy
score between the two of them
is going to get to pick which color
they're playing with so
why is ludwig not mating criticism
trying to
marinate him and enjoy the process a
little bit more
he's playing with his food here there
was a mismating one however
pretty much anything in this position is
still winning
so we're good
all right okay
there is mating 2 with queen c3 king d1
and
either rook takes c1 or queen takes c1
so
and he sees it there you go well all
right
that does it the score is tied
all right and the clock has been
adjusted ludwig is playing the counter
sicilian once again
let's see if moist critical is still
going to oh okay so he pushes his pawn
to d5 right away instead of what he
played last game which was d6
how are you feeling about his opening
nemo ah this will be very interesting i
think he's playing it correctly this
is the alpine so d5 is the correct
response and
i wonder what line charlie has maybe
taken a look at during his break or
maybe
had actually prepared beforehand and
instead of just
rapidly moving g6 uh instead of
d5 on move three maybe he asked leaving
this line before
castle
okay good normal developing moves castle
is great
critical castles as well and work oh
this is looking like game one
bishop e3 this will get
intense really quick now i can take this
there's a threat here for sure
oh
okay take now i'm playing knight c3
knight c3 great developing move uh
critical has to get out his bishop on f8
that's the theme we've seen today with
all of these scandinavian like
structures
you haven't pushed your e or g pawn so
you do need to find a fast way to
develop
i i would like to see critical try not
to make the gap
of one minute even larger than it
already is but unfortunately that's
where it's trending
two minutes 23 seconds he's now down two
minutes
on ludwig and there's no increment that
is huge
his queen is going to be trapped after
the knight moves even 92
a simple move like that the queen cannot
move uh if ludwig sees it
i think this is his game and he sees it
this is brutal
that will be a pinned queen and there is
actually no way for black to get out of
that pin
he should cry oh i didn't even notice it
was a pin
whoops yeah even after bishop takes f3
you can play queen takes f3
okay so rook oh
no critical only gets a rook for the
queen
and the bishop now ludwig is just up way
too much material this is
feeling very very doomed unfortunately
for critical
yeah i mean he shouldn't give up
of course 2 30 to 1 30. maybe he'll find
some kind of crazy perpetual
but the hardest thing now is going to be
not getting his spirits down once you
blunder a queen in this situation you've
almost given up completely so if he can
keep his head in the game
i'd say you know he still has like a 5
10 chance of come back which is better
than nothing
of course i mean there's always a chance
which is why you should never resign
um especially in blitz when anything
could happen right
yeah in 1966 would have been so juicy
but
uh ludwig didn't see it that's okay he
has so many chances here there's also
like knight c6 there's just so many
oh 96 now especially just forking the
king and the rook
and black cannot take back with a b pawn
because it was pinned
but um honestly anything in this
position is pretty much winning for
ludwig
and those are not words you want to hear
if you're with the black side of the
pieces here anything your opponent does
is fine right
yeah pretty much it's just up way too
much material
oh and and ludwig doesn't go for for the
knight c6 or knight a6 but he's playing
quickly
he is slowly draining
critical's time here on top of the fact
that he has such a hard position to play
i like rookie 8 it's a good attempt
i like i do like this i mean just in
case white doesn't
you know spot that the queen is under
attack however ludwig does see it
plays queen c2 um there's just so many
great ideas in this position for why to
try to check mate
critical uh 96 there's going to c5 just
putting everything at wow wow
wow that's a good move and because once
his knight moves to c6
then his bishop is going to be
supporting his queen to get to a7 if
ludwig sees this
uh he is just killing it the cool thing
is how much progress they've both made
since pogchamps won
i think critical i mean
okay that's a good attempt this is a
good attempt knight to c6
with a check the knight d to c6 to be
precise because um
you're just leaving your fish you're
opening up your bishop and now
it will be checkmate next move after b
takes c6 or
wow yep queen to a7 he didn't even flag
him he just
beat him on the board that is brutal
what was it like being paired against
each other ludwig maybe you first
uh i look i i want to play charlie in
one match in one match only that's the
finals
everything else i uh don't i don't care
to play him
uh more of a lover than a fighter
against him but
uh you know i also did not want to play
el dorado
so i uh definitely wanted to win this
one for that reason
and uh what about you charlie oh you
well
you called us friends and now i can't
talk because you've made it more
wholesome than i expected it to be
i didn't want to play ludwig because i
thought he was the strongest player here
uh and he absolutely slapped me in the
last two games so i felt a full fury
from lud
well to make you feel a little bit
better charlie we have this first game
where you beat him pulled up
and this was a fun game dude
ready for the goddamn uh scandinavian
i practiced for the scandinavian but you
didn't play it the way i expected so i
kind of just went off instinct there
raw primal i was gonna do this did you
know i was gonna do the scandy
no no i had no idea oh god yeah you
crushed it i was like yeah he's gonna
have no clue what to do and you're just
making every correct move
and then i forgot even though i prepared
the line halfway through and i felt like
you still knew what you were doing
uh i just had plans that didn't work out
and then i got lucky is really what
happened there
yeah and you guys are showing this sack
that i did
which i think was dumb i thought it'd
just be an equal trade
and then apparently i'm supposed to pin
his knight to
his queen and i don't think there's a
universe where i would have seen that uh
well we're going for checkmate here
right was that the plan
yeah yeah yeah so you want me to rook
lift
yeah i want you to recklessly okay let's
just back up a moment
i'm one thousand rated i don't rook lift
i
occasionally push it but you know what
rook lift is
yeah cause pros do it i'm just as sure
what but you know it so
you can do it too oh you're you're more
than that
oh you're better than that charlie stop
you rook lift charlie
i have all the time i never stop rook
lifting
what are you looking forward to in the
championship
bracket i don't even know who i play
apparently you play dwight so i mean if
you play
logic you'll play rain oh oh jesus
okay christ oh all right i think i'm on
benji's side and you're on sardosh's
side
and then xqc is also somewhere mixed in
but let's play sardoche first so we'll
see about that
okay it'll be very poetic if you guys
you know
claw your way through all these heavy
opponents only to meet for the final
championship match i think both of your
fans would be really excited to see that
my dream we both meet in the finals yeah
that'd be so nice hunger games style
we both eat the blueberries we don't
finish out the game
it's a draw we're both winners we leave
hand in hand
never has another tournament it's
charity after all that could be huge
yeah it's chair what are they gonna do
charlie if we just play
zero moves oh i don't know those
chest snobs would lose their mind in the
chat
yeah yeah it's it and it's their fault
all right they did a game that you can
tie in that's the problem with chess
that's why this armageddon exists yeah
chess.com listening right now thinking
how are we going to stop
these two from accomplishing that you
can't stop
us you can only hope to contain us yeah
you have to boost uh
uh sardoche with like the limitless drug
so they can attempt to beat charlie and
me
yeah yeah that's what they'll have to do
well i love how supportive you two are
of each other and also just how close
and head-to-head you've been for so long
thank you so much charlie and ludwig for
coming on for the interview well played
by both and
i'm hoping both of you are able to
somehow meet and eat the berries
together
at the end thank you so much